this episode is brought to you by
t-mobile now Netflix has included
another reason why t-mobile is America's
best unlimited network switch today
hello everybody welcome to the
Australian commentary for Wonder Woman
and I was gonna do two because I don't
know if it was a gang sign so I just
it is a gang sign handy for Wonder
Woman's or Wes constantly no yeah anyway
this is I found this to be a wonderful
film and we'll be talking about it as
well as watching the honest trailer that
we just released today and share some
deleted scenes and I'm as always next to
Joe star hello Joe hey man it's really
excited about the response to this
trailer yes we're getting into it I'm
glad they liked it Spencer J Gilbert dan
and I have done the fusion dance I am
now dancer Wow Wow
so Wonder Woman this was that I mean I
don't want to start there but it was a
tougher one just be in that it's a
better film so usually when we have the
better films they're tougher to do
Spencer Joe what were your thoughts on a
tackle on this one it's a good movie it
is a good standard-issue comic book
movie that I think's elevated because
you put a director with a different POV
and a lead character with a different
point of view and that elevates it
that's like sort of a little bit of
difference elevates it past sort of the
usual well here's a Marvel thing and
it's got the usual problems but we like
it because it's you know yeah yeah I'm
always when you sing whether a movie is
good or bad I was trying to like by what
standard by what context DC movie this
is great yep yes superhero movie this is
good movie it's fine yeah that was kind
of my take away was like it's a good
superhero movie it's a great DC movie
and it's a fine movie movie yeah I don't
disagree with any of that she's it's
really great packaging is such a good
job of just making her stand alone and
strongly and he wanted to root for her
like I agree though it's it's a
superhero movie still but you know
there's moments that she fought for pi
Jenkins especially like that no man's
land scene etc like just it really
affected me and I thought she does a
fantastic job so it was a kudos I think
it's a great it is a fun good movie
but yes as we mentioned that third act
gets really silly oh man they fall from
like every spear movie cliche in the
book this did it all but I've got to the
point where like I'm so used to ever no
comic book movies really being able to
like overcome that terrible third act
that I hard to do like I just sort of
strap it in a mic and here comes the
terrible third act I like her though the
sign was good in that third act he saved
me he helped me get through it yeah it's
like I'm with you I serve like alright I
like the first two-thirds so I'll give
it this one and give it a little bit of
bass but um yeah it didn't need to go so
big big bad at the end yeah it's just
the expectations thing like you now need
to subvert that I thought hey we'll let
the rest of the movie but Doctor Strange
was really good in that we're you or
even Civil War where they're setting up
the big epic showdown that's gonna be
the big CGI disposable army or big gray
blob of a bad guy and then they pull the
rug out from under you they did at first
in this movie they did it out of order
at first there was like a subversive
ending where like oh wow like the the
pet guy was inside us all along right no
no it was like right before that
happened there's no more I was like oh
man like I could really go cool itself
and she's gonna have to deal with the
fact that she has a brother that like
you know and they're gonna set him up
for later like maybe Wonder Woman - he
puts on the big dumb helmet you know I
felt like dr. poison actually was kind
of interesting character that I wish we
could have learned more about she was
interesting looking care was the birth
of something good and then they never
developed her enough to give her that
and I'm saying instead of re Ares they
should have given her that sort of arc
and given her figure out ways to use her
more because there was something
interesting to her was it you that said
that they should have just had her and
not also Ludendorff yeah and there's a
large those and just let her be the
weird crazy I don't mr. Edwin Ludendorff
but you didn't really need it yeah yeah
why not have you had it we have the
awesome female hero when I have an
awesome hero yeah female and then if you
need you know if you have to go the
route of RA it's this guy it's the guy
who wants peace that turns out to be the
God of War you don't need to show his
face because
is the sickly esteem and yes apologies
David Lewis amazing actor it's great and
Fargo is granted a ton of things we were
moving though for him it looks like like
mr. Burns's like diseased cousin and and
Nestor burns being propped up in an
armoire - yes at the end of Wolfenstein
3d when Hitler gets inside the giant
robot suit it's like this tiny little
head and this giant robot body it just
something else mark honks off yeah yeah
exactly yeah I think if they had gone
the route of hey I'm just gonna kind of
tell you like it is here and we're gonna
do sort of a weird quiet sad ending he
would have worked because he has like
the acting range to be able to do it but
the other moment he's like yeah it's
weird to the audience - yeah I'm curious
- the audience feel like they needed
that and comment below and tell us about
it but did you really need I feel like
these movies to sort of feel obligated
to spend all this money on the third act
finale where they okay all the
characters already resolved so they're
gonna punch it out and win we know
what's gonna happen yeah don't need that
it's frustrating that they feel the need
to have to deliver and I think if they
had gone something more in-depth or
actually tell a story there they still
gonna have some final but battle between
two people but yeah I wish they would
have they would have like I feel like
they did the rest of movie that showed
us this new point of view and then they
just resorted to the same old same old
at the very very end yeah which was a
bummer but like the movie the movie yeah
as you said well it's a comic book movie
it's a great kind of book yeah it's
weird how you can think both of those
things without your brain exploding it's
weird oh you can have both of those
thoughts it was good and flood no not a
lot Joe it's either good or bad rotten
or fresh ragnar fresh best ever worst
ever you see your marvel yeah pick one
see hey Johnson come to my house and be
my dad
it's not coming not coming back Joe well
should we watch it yeah yeah let's do it
I know the first thing we're all gonna
yell Pau Zhaan see see what we did there
guys a lot of see from the comments
about to me that mostly women one of
this trailer that's been man is LexA T
with intelligence and self-absorbed
owners with heroism the DC EU pulls up
its biggest success yet by not doing
those things
Cavan TJ that's work Alec Wonder Woman
after Supergirl Catwoman and Electra
Studios doubted a female led superhero
movie could succeed now patty Jenkins
bravely asks the question what if a
female at superhero movie was an
absolute garbage from beginning to end
it's fair to say Kalin had a powerful
message for girls now save the world
look flawless doing it be a literal God
then men might begrudgingly have
tolerate your presence sir if this woman
can read it we should hear what she has
to say acting performance technician a
perfect like he's great I was surprised
he was in such a small scene that guy's
in lots of stuff yeah that was a weird
like one line day for him I guess he's
just like he'll come do it patty I've
got an hour yeah wondering is Wonder
Woman gonna get credit for any of what
she did at the end yeah cuz like though
he was definitely seen by many people
yeah the only people who can vouch for
like smugglers or Chris Pine blew up and
like spoiler alert yes I think she's
going back to a world no wonder she went
back to the island because everyone's
dismay like yeah yeah yeah sure sure
abroad she would like to the Louvre
Spencer she never went back to the
island you can't go back she will talk
about the timeline later sort of but
yeah she she is collecting all the
evidence right isn't that Jimmy evidence
yeah like the photos she wants all the
sort of evidence that she was there yeah
well is the photo is the last thing that
sort of existed it from that time so I
remember
she just like lazily no she can't go
back well they say in the movie she
can't go back we are gonna see more if
the mascara in Justice League Premier
League her mom's like if you decide to
do this she can't go but I was like when
I left for college and my parents were
like bye ya can't go home even weirder
that she didn't show up in World War two
that she was there watching it there or
any effect stopping up in Laden you same
there's a lot of stuff she sat through
Ross and Rachel breaking up well that I
understand yeah anyway settle in for an
origin story about the Greek gods inside
an origin story for Wonder Woman inside
an origin story for world war two so
about this joke seen a lot of comments
just director came on concerts telling
us that this movie actually took place
in World War one
now we're aware of this I think anybody
who saw the movie is aware of this now
you either didn't see the movie
that camera now look I will admit to a
mistake I didn't see which camera I was
supposed to be looking at but you need
to admit that your Titanic a little bit
[ __ ] more you didn't get that joke I
will look it's on us if we tell a joke
that nobody understands but no I am
going to war with this one I'm going to
world man one with this one because I
know the difference between World War
one and that was the joke that was the
joke and then I was thinking to myself
you know what is it too obvious that we
play the clip of him saying armistice
the thing that directly led to World War
two we should probably cut back because
people probably get it right and yet no
we put it in lengthening the trailer
patting it out just to drive the point
home to make it extra obvious and you
people who are eating paste and then
firing up YouTube somehow
Gonzaga operate a supercomputer with
your one ham hand slapping a firstborn
with your flipper somehow managed to
type out a comment if you said if you
type the comment this actually takes
place during World War one and thought
you were giving us some type of insight
indeed their comedy or the movie or
history take your ham ham and choke on
it and die and never watch three zombies
video again thank you really bug me I
start seeing them this morning like
that's the joke the joke is that warmer
one's the origin story for World War two
know your history guys it's late
that was World War one a lot more droids
in Italy led to the events that made the
Galactic Civil exactly thank you Jeff
you're welcome
just want to put it in terms people
would understand watch the look of the
line again at an origin story for a
World War two the people commenting or
don't understand what armistice is right
clearly they didn't they're not getting
the joke that anyway I don't know what
to do for them this was a world war it's
the origin for world war two because it
took place in World War one guys Treaty
of Versailles guys look it up uh the
origin for World War two
they don't understand war to place the
on his trailer with that amount and
visit that Messiah in Miss Korea the the
miscarriages
for your island a society of women
trained from birth to cover for gal
gadot's access to the greatest worry in
our history you need to tell us behind
we're making a joke about it but I
actually love that they did yeah instead
of just being like because most movies I
think would have been like Greek British
accents and I love that because she has
like a strong accent they were like just
make everybody sound like that and salt
which PBS it was already cannon that she
talks like the Swedish Chef fix that
then somehow make make sense that's the
continuity how much they that was in
tension I was like okay well you can't
work on the accent you are its cannon
now everyone else just talking of weird
European accent such a good I think it
sort of helps because every other movie
if it's not set in the United States
everyone just has a British accent if
it's Rome or Far East or Argentina
everyone's just British for some reason
everyone and Thor is is British they're
not Scandinavian yeah so I like this
yeah I know I thought was clever but
it's also fun to point out that yeah
here let me put it like that's really
why they all have the accent because
she's speaking in her regular accent so
we have to have other would be weird if
everyone else is speaking one excellent
it is weird that I can like it and also
write a joke about it that's weird too
these Amazon's have been preparing their
whole lives to fight the God of War Ares
and you can bet that when war reaches
their shores they'll get rekt by German
teams with you have actually been around
since 500 years the other
I'm totally nitpicking here but the only
thing that's wrong that shops the war
the fight on the beach like stops right
when they need it to when when Robin
Wright gets spoiler killed yeah
happening everyone's shooting at each
other the beach and then suddenly no and
then Mara where I can see all the other
soldiers are dead at that right point so
they can all have a moment together we
state those from Oh fighting
choreography standpoint like I get it
there's a story beating you there but
like finish the battle before we come
and also I get it look cool to like
rappel down the cliff but I mean come on
guys Star Wars you have the high ground
yeah yeah there's a deleted scene where
Tiffany the archer who is the greatest
Archer in the Miss Korea just shoots
like 15 arrows at once and just mercs
the rest of them yeah but they just you
know cut for time no but no you're
saying yeah no Tiffany the archer not
cannon season these are Elvis's mommies
Bria maybe you send out a scout once
every 500 years or at least employ some
of your invisible Jets I know you have
them me Diana a girl never actually
referred to as Wonder Woman she's the
hero the decent you know doesn't deserve
but sure as hell needs right now she's
optimistic confident iron-willed
vulnerable uncompromising and just so
hard I could say that right I mean I
don't wanna come off like James Cameron
cuz it's definitely not the only thing
she's got going for but damn pawn store
I put Dan too much on blast he's not
here to defend himself he's like I
actually find Robin right I don't want
to make this the thing at the same time
like that she is I feel like is a good
job calling it out to or dawn Tinsley is
like oh yeah yeah you put glasses on her
and she's not
homey tale no one will ever recognize
her yeah it's one of those things really
are we laughs but then it's like how do
yes we have to it this is that's a
definitely bake makes me feel like oh my
god she's beautiful she's beautiful yeah
but she's also all of those other things
and then the James Cameron was way to
get that quote in there that was a
unpopular quote from a lot of people
yeah of him tingling around as a bad
female one one-dimensional female
character something about because of her
outfit I thought crap one of the details
I love about this movie is like her
armor is like functional yeah guys are
free for both sides are free okay we
have a joke yeah but it makes your kick
better yeah but it was great that's that
they all ran around in those weird
little tunic armors with their little
bear legs hanging out yeah sure and some
easy well as you could have gone just
pure sexy because something we didn't
get into is the actual origin story of
hunt women which is like some weird guy
in like the open marriage with the
bondage stuff yeah look that one up yeah
they didn't go there they did nicely the
lasso of truth and I'm making a movie
about that which I'm fascinated about
the Creator yeah I'll cop to uh in the
cop with the comics I've always ever
known and then they'll do like a you
know an armoured leg version of that and
I'm always like yeah just do that
because she's supposed to be wear an
armor and the costumes like a little too
sexy and dated but I mean this is pretty
much the classic comic costume and it
works on screen I because I was not
expecting it to when I was like they're
not giving her armor legs
you can't run at normal eggs yeah get
harder she does a lot of kicking and
jumping also let's be honest 10 thighs
is bulletproof yeah I think she is right
you can't hit those legs
you can't touch those legs touch this
button and it she's stronger faster and
smarter than the men around her but
every superhero has a kryptonite and
hers is not knowing jack about anything
war what war it's a watch toast time
what for
why are they holding hands what do these
women wearing
to battle is the average man not sleep
but is a secretary at the front with the
front of what marries you speak a
hundred languages you know what Barry
Bonds Lake Spencer you miss anything
else no I think it speaks for himself
but I mean she's a warrior and she's
like they make this point that she's so
well studied she's read all these books
and stuff like that like even if you
haven't seen a marriage you can read
about it in like it's on a man and a
woman get married are like she's a
warrior
you know what the front is that's a
pretty basic military term and this is
the kind of nitpick that you guys write
yeah it's it's a small detail but I
don't know it they kind of wanted it
both ways of like she's so well steady
shadow water but you want that my fair
lady section in the middle which I liked
but it you know we got to point out
bother me as much in the movie when you
make it out of context and put them all
back to back it does seem a little say
it didn't it didn't bother me with for
where it's like he's perplexed by coffee
and it's like you've had a warm beverage
before like come on dude you've been
alive for a zillion years we're come on
a horse
yeah there was some fun Thor didn't bug
me too much but yeah the marriage one
I'll defecate mattress I should know
they're just you know a lot of other
things they were talking about there's a
few like there's a few in that run where
I think she's just picking at him like
do you not sleep like just man up and
sleep next to me right what does sex
what that's all other debate which we
won't get into here the island sexual
politics of be honest yes breaking
superhero movie but not so
groundbreaking that they didn't put one
of the bankable Hollywood Chris's in it
Chris Pine surprises and delivers gives
him his first league heart is that true
not me yeah okay talk me into having
Pratt that I I think that Chris's I
think hasn't had anything in a while so
basically the movie typos or did we mean
to tie them for third yeah weird wait no
I think it's about to change because it
was shifting I mean I don't
I hope so now anyway nope no for heavens
and hmmm sure it's about to have four
which should put a lot but you're saying
like hat just yeah what in terms of
having the most recent movie because it
what are we it's like who I think like
the hottest no well that's a factor
that's one many factors it's the hottest
it's the best acting it's like the most
likeable because I think Chris Pratt
yeah he's in more movies in more recent
movies but he's wearing out his welcome
more so like I would be more excited
that there's a new Chris Evans movie
coming out than a new Chris Pratt movie
hmm
I was surprised we put as much thought
into this graphic I was just like Kris
Kristofferson should be hired to I was
like let's just put it it'd be funny if
we had a weird cranking of the Chris's
Chris Hemsworth second actually I think
I like Hemsworth even yeah I think every
Evans is my top chris is your top Chris
Evans is your top and this is my top
Chris I think he's like the most
interesting as far as like he can
probably act outside of Captain America
the best what's giving you that that
reasoning aside from Pratt can't
Pratt should be so much lower Pratt
cannot act yeah but I feel like and he
can carry like a TV show which he was a
good I'm Parks and Rec yeah but for me
Evans is so good at Captain America and
and what Oh piercer and he's showed like
his interest in doing sir he showed some
Sun lights on pine winds just because
not only was he greatness but hell or
high water just completely look through
my pillar I was sorry I I do agree Pines
on an on an uptick its pine Evans for me
Hemsworth I think also has anyway where
we where do you stand on the hot crate
Hollywood Chris off tells the coming I
might put Pratt below crystals use your
top Chris my top Chris is a pine than
Hemsworth yeah Evans Pratt well Evans
Kristofferson Pratt I'm fine a much fine
Hemsworth right now I'm waiting for
comes worth to really have a good meaty
dramatic role yeah he can't black hand
he's been okay but it's not yeah but I
feel like he and heavens are sort of
neck-and-neck
mmm but I feel like Hemsworth show
comedy chops and Ghostbusters and in
vacation was it mmm-hmm Hemsworth
actually and he was really fine and
sterile I've had his earth his life has
that going for him on top of being
really good
thora whereas I haven't seen enough
evans other stuff but i'm sure he has it
in them we will see this chart will
continue to change that's even great
Hollywood Chris off but he's more than
just eye candy
he's Diana's emotional support a voice
of caution and a love interest in
constant need of rescue hey they give
him the role women always have to play
against the male superheroes didn't they
I see what you do there in a film with
two grounded complex leads cringe at
villains pulled from a different much
campy your movie the Germans in World
War one were not the Nazis one of the
good guys
guys seriously expects us to buy this
human milk thistle as the God of War for
all okay yeah no go ahead Judy here
comes up Hitler in dollars alright go
ahead keep your head down for all of
Hitler and Stalin but did suit up the
moment Lex Luthor made a ninja turtle
you know what I'm sorry for even
bringing BBS into this class let's just
look this was a this was the timeline
thing we've talked about this but it
does sort of oddly doesn't make sense
why she it just this felt like they were
went into this corner of thanks to BBS
where it's like just shut up so let's
yeah I wonder what they'll do with
Wonder Woman to her prequel or like a
continuation cuz she could come back and
then I don't know erase everyone's
memory or something like that just
leaves no trace I really don't want it
to be a pretty cool I want it to be you
take I remember those weird Clash of the
Titans remakes they did I want you to
take all that stuff put at present day
and then Wonder Woman just fights it
that sounds dumb I think the reason I
would like I wouldn't be too mad at
another prequel is it frees you from
having to tie in all this I'm like you
can keep giving her her own stories and
not worry about like well where's Green
Lantern from so they've got a story is
so powerful though it's like who is she
up against that because they have all
these movies have to hug you up becoming
someone's can have to go up against
someone even stronger they do the
classic superhero thing we're like oh
the your powers got taken by the orb hmm
they they be powered Thor they do power
super manly but when you're too powerful
that's what all you can do true when are
they gonna learn to just not go near
orbs you don't touch the orb stop tucked
in those orbs superheroes it's gonna
take your powers yeah always does oh
yeah the seek will be very very
interesting because they'll probably go
forward
yep ending out justice well learn more
as Justice League comes cuz apparently
we'll see more of the island what's he
gone let's just let this one stand on
its own so get ready for a film about
balancing the good and bad in all of us
that contains good and bad within itself
in this flawed but important movie
that's no less important for having
flaws is it an inspirational well-made
film that finally gives women a
superhero to be proud of yes does it end
with a lightning hands moustache man
yelling videogame level dialogue and I
believe in Wonder Woman if you're
watching this park yeah was sad too
because the pine stuff was working for
me like that sort of himself sacrifice
and her learning oh no that was enough
of a lesson that she needed to learn
I was excited when she could finally win
and fight back but it was very silly and
he was a silly yeah you're waiting for
one of the Howling Commandos to like
call in like Metal Gear Solid and just
being like Wonder Woman interesting if
you actually had her like give up and
walk away on mankind and like Chris Pine
saves the day and that explains why she
left yeah like she just that'd be a like
a gut punch of an ending where she's
like well I guess war is up to men like
maybe I'll come back someday when
they're worthy of it yeah her brother
kind of screws up her head with that cuz
he like makes him cool point like I like
his point of view and he didn't have to
turn into the big bad guy at the end you
can still shut up and sort of like see
you in there
yeah and the whole like love is the like
the interstellar ending again it doesn't
work because they weren't I mean they
had started to be in love but she hadn't
experienced enough of the world to
really be like no if this guy is really
keeping me here for all yeah but yeah I
like that cuz it wasn't this it wasn't
just a standard like oh we love each
other like there it was a more of a
complicated love and I feel like she
just appreciated each other it's all
learning about each other and that felt
more like a realistic I like to sort of
rare in these movies it's also like your
first love and like for her that's like
you know you're weird like high school
like first serious boyfriend where
you're like this is my boyfriend and I
will die for him like that's kind of
what that was for her so I think it
would have that level of impact cuz
there are a lot of comments to that were
like this was in feminism sure she was
strong but she was also second-guessing
herself all the time and loved a man and
it's like she can also do those things
girls aren't allowed to do that Joe I'm
sorry you're right yeah I think three
white guys who were at this I can say
that it's feminist in the sense that
she's like full-fledged characters she's
got three dimensions it's not she's like
just the generic strong woman or just
the generic damsel in distress like
she's not just there to support the man
not just there to support someone else's
story and she's got a lot going on what
she does is not up to you yeah that's
the line from the movie she can do war
just as well as the boys yes sure can
and the kissing stuff starring Amazon
Pride want to touch the Piney like that
also the Queen what hater
she was this karate boy drunk Scotsman
uh sneaky Frenchman a wise old Indian
guide what are these guys the howling
stereotypes perhaps Lee I mean dawn
Tinsley
dun-dun-duh and schneider vision just as
the road yeah yeah no charlie one thing
for us
your friend clearly has PTSD sweet
trying to make him not feel worthless
but yeah just send him home yeah I'm
chillin
yeah that's I don't wanna see any more
Schneider vision ever again well what do
you mean slow-mo slow-motion okay so it
works in the matrix because the matrix
isn't real
it worked in 300 because 300 is a movie
about a guy telling his soldiers a big
[ __ ] story to get them pumped to go
charge at these other guys so it works
it's stylized it's a it's fake he's
telling you a story it doesn't work in
these like maybe once or twice but they
just keep going to it like every time
she runs into one of those rooms where
she's taking back the town it's like you
can't do it with all of it just do it
with the first one one sheet you were
the one that we photoshopped the DVD
covers on like do it that one that one's
fine that's it that's a great shot but
like every time she points her leg got a
guy's face like just let me see it yeah
don't eat it don't eat it all right yeah
that's my room doesn't need it that's my
sad ran up I don't mind it once in a
while but I agree he over does it and
the Peggy Jenkins I know his case it was
introduced though in Donna dress it's
become part of the visual vocabulary of
the DC bug me as much in this
surprisingly for some reason I thought
she did it a little bit I don't know it
felt a little bit more fluid but yeah I
see your complaint it's a fair it's
valid it's a lot of it
that's my movie Fire argument for when
we do that that topic all right we never
will see but one critical weakness her
thighs would you did her thighs you
fools that you can't be everywhere
still I thought she was with you that
was shoot assess die Chris Steve Evans
Rogers pine Trevor is almost Color Me
behind those hips don't lie I put my
hand up on your head
Right Said dad what happened
Robin right well let's not have gotten
to Robert in time right said dead is
pretty great glare bring up our lair
wonder would Claire wonder what dork bat
not even once
captain britain mr. bird his head i'm
smelt it dealt it don't know what i'm a
woman though first justice sir captain
america I get it yeah there were I think
that um in general we try not to see
what other people are doing just to
avoid being accused of ripping off cuz
but I can't resist Rena how it should
have ended comes out there because it
comes out so infrequently yeah I had to
watch yeah like they really hit the
Captain America thing hard and did a
great job doing it and I was like no I
don't know better to say yeah so people
are wondering why we didn't make that
point
well ya know I'd I agree the I just lost
my chose Steven Steve Rogers Evans pint
right that was a good name that almost
made the yeah that's a Sandler right I
won't touch the hiney I mean piny is a
very attractive man yeah I guess I think
of Sandler you know 98 previous is
different completely different kind this
new movies in is amazing the one with
Ben Stiller really yeah it's a dramatic
role he's doing because it is ooh later
so it's apparently amazing I don't know
I'm very curious it's a good dry it's a
the guy who did squid in the whale and
all those movies
that is like beautician character really
don't mess with the Zohan yeah yeah
that's your favorite yeah
does that could see him showing up on
Wonder Woman Island hi hi
well I do not want to see that he wasn't
gonna read Israeli barber yeah told your
guy right yeah yeah yeah forgot I block
that movie on his own man
it's all Haim the god stylist maybe
someone put that together at the matchup
anything else to add fellas
now yeah you can like movies and not be
a Marvel junkie or DC hater I think it's
weird that we're still DC haters even
though we clearly liked this movie does
she not count the night has turned start
making our Marvel later yeah look you
could stop making fun of decent making
everybody mad I think we're doing
something right yeah we did it and read
a book just any book start with World
War one yeah how about one about yeah
start with anything really
google it how about that Google don't
know read a book that's it will be you
next week with another honest trailer as
always and then we'll be commentating on
it right afterwards I have a great week
this episode is brought to you by
t-mobile
want to hear how America's best
unlimited network is upping their game
now get Netflix included with your
family glad there's never been a better
time to switch
you